former Massachusetts governor Deval
Patrick is with us and we are very
excited to announce that Governor
Patrick is our newest CBS News political
contributor we're so happy about that
he's going to provide his insights to us
throughout this 2020 election gonna be a
lot to discuss from now until November
indeed let's start with this a debate
last night we just heard what the
students were saying about who stood out
anybody stand out to you I think they
all had their moments yeah which is I
think of all of the all of the debates I
thought the openings were particularly
strong they I think in every case
offered a vision of unity and how
important it is of the comfort that the
country come back together after the
election which is you know almost
inherently and inevitably divisive and
but we've had you know unanimous grounds
for who Leon Castro after he made the
comment where he seemed to be taking a
stab at Joe Biden's necessary you know
you can there are differences in how the
candidates view their policy choices and
their policy proposals and that is all
fair game but it doesn't have to be
trivialized how do you attack without
making it personal though you're going
to stand out you're trying to make a
moment how do you do that the way we do
in regular conversation with people we
respect you have conversation I do all
the time we have all do with people who
who don't agree with us and what we have
to do is project a politics that says we
don't have to agree on everything yeah
before we work together on anything the
Vice President got mixed reviews last
night how did you how do you think he
did I think he started really strong it
felt over time and I've felt this before
about a vice president about Joe Biden
whom I really admire and like personally
that he sometimes takes umbrage at being
asked questions at being challenged that
he has such a long record it's kind of
obvious where he where he stands on a
given policy issue and I think that
there's some surprise to get back into
of just relaxing when he's challenged
that's part of it the last time you're
at the table with us you said the
Democrats should not talk about
President Trump all the time but we had
Amy Klobuchar and we had common law
Harris in their opening statements you
know right at the president would you
think of that well look we are
campaigning against Donald Trump so I
get that my point was and still is that
he can't be the the sole reason that
candidates are in the race and can't be
the sole reason an objective of the
Democratic Party to unseat him we have
to be talking about what comes after a
successful Democratic campaign what is
our vision for how we serve not just the
people who voted for Democrats but for
everybody is that something Medicare for
all which may be overreaching for some
voters but maybe not is the Democratic
Party too progressive if it forces
people to accept a government health
care option well look i think i think
medicare for all has become a kind of a
slogan for a lot of different versions
of how we extend health care to everyone
i think the the the central point is
that everybody on that stage and the
democrats in general believe that
everyone should have access to
affordable high-quality care and the
other side does not personally I think
having a private health insurance
industry is important to have alongside
government supply to health care because
not frankly because I care about the
insurance industry but because that that
the innovation that comes from the
private sector can be beneficial for how
we think about improving government I
thought a recent CBS News poll was very
interesting found former Vice President
Biden is considered the most
presidential but senator Warren is
considered the most knowledgeable which
quality do you think is the most
important in 2020 nuclear yeah I know
it's gonna say I'm gonna say both you
know look I think I think that the that
the president I want and he's like the
president I think most Americans want
which is someone who is not going to
spend their day every day trying to
figure out how to divide us but instead
how to bring us together and it is it
has turned out I think that if you look
closely there are common feelings of
economic anxiety social anxiety
even in these statistically prosperous
time that are shared across all kinds of
communities in all kinds of places and
ways in which people who feel left out
and left back that that sentiment is
shared very broadly so I'm looking for
someone who is interested in in policy
but is above all interested in leading
us back to back to you well there are
candidates last night that will say
that's me back up the next debate you
can tell us if anyone emerges as that
person Governor Patrick thank you very
much to be with you